Це крилата ракета Taurus шведсько-німецького виробництва.
Вона може вражати цілі на відстані до 500 кілометрів.
У Німеччини на озброєнні 600 таких ракет.
І вони б знадобилися Україні.
Київ, а також українські активісти, які живуть в Німеччині,
наполегливо просять у Берліна про поставки.
Цими ракетами - саме Taurus - можна цілитися по штабах російських дронів
та російських ракет і таким чином можна забезпечувати безпеку українським родинам,
дітям, людям уже на етапі виробництва російських ракет та дронів.
Саме далекобійність цих ракет - їхня головна перевага і та причина,
з якої Німеччина зволікає з їхньою передачею Україні.
Великобританія та Франція вже постачають Києву крилаті ракети,
але радіус дії Taurus майже вдвічі більший.
Країни НАТО домовилися про те,
що не можна допустити втягування альянсу в цей конфлікт.
І Вашингтон, і Берлін надають цьому особливого значення.
І тому ключовий момент тут - далекобійність озброєнь,
які ми поставляємо і за допомогою яких можна атакувати цілі,
які не пов'язані безпосередньо з військовими діями в Україні.
До того ж Німеччина не хоче діяти самотужки.
У минулому німецька влада завжди погоджувала свої поставки
з партнерами по коаліції - насамперед зі США.
А Вашингтон поки що теж не планує передавати Україні крилаті ракети.
Міністр оборони Німеччини Борис Пісторіус налаштований скептично.
За його словами, крилаті ракети зараз "не в пріоритеті".
Штрак-Ціммерманн, яка очолює оборонний комітет німецького Бундестагу,
вважає, що вже час дати "зелене світло" передачі Україні далекобійних ракет Taurus.
За її словами, цьому перешкоджають у відомстві канцлера.
Тим часом повільність уряду критикує опозиція.
Передати Україні Taurus закликав депутат Бундестагу від ХДС Родеріх Кізеветтер.
Україна в ситуації, коли діяти треба негайно.
Міжнародні союзники, які підтримують Україну, мають діяти проактивно.
Тому що масові жертви українців справді жахливі
й українському народу потрібні перспективи.
Однією з таких перспектив є звільнення Криму шляхом перерізання комунікацій,
усіх ланцюгів постачання з Росії.
Для того, щоб відрізати шляхи постачання озброєнь через Крим
і потрібні далекобійні ракети Taurus, переконаний депутат.
Він також наполягає, що про можливу ескалацію через використання ракет
для вражання цілей на території Росії не може йти мови.
І що це не має завадити Німеччині передати ракети Україні.
Єдина сторона, яка йде на ескалацію - це агресор, і це Росія.
Росіяни могли б негайно зупинити війну.
На всі кроки з заспокоєння ситуації з нашого боку
- зволікання з рішенням щодо артилерії,
зволікання з рішенням щодо БМП і танків
- Росія відповіла новими звірствами та жахливими діями.
Є лише одне обмеження - не воювати проти цивільних цілей в Росії.
Україна легко зможе дотриматися цього.
Тому нам потрібно протидіяти ескалації та зупинити російське домінування.
З цього тижня до критики уряду приєдналася й низка політиків
із Соціал-демократичної партії Німеччини, що входить до коаліції.
Якщо уважно послухати Бориса Пісторіуса,
він не проти постачання, просто вважає, що час ще не настав.
Але я іншої думки.
Звичайно для нашої країни постачати зброю в зону конфлікту
- це зміна парадигми, це нелегко, це не просте рішення,
але якщо подивитися на останні місяці,
ми, звичайно, думали надто довго над прийняттям того чи іншого рішення,
і в результаті воно все одно було прийнято
- спільно з нашими партнерами - і озброєння було поставлено.
Андреас Шварц сподівається, що цього разу дискусія так довго не затягнеться.
На це розраховують і в Україні.
А активісти Vitsche за допомогою медіакампанії у соцмережах
закликають німецький уряд діяти якнайшвидше
і готуються виходити на мітинг.
Ми не можемо чекати, поки йдуть ці довгі-довгі розмови
з приводу постачання озброєнь, постачання Taurus,
бо щохвилини німецький уряд сумнівається,
постачати ці ракети чи ні, українське ППО не справляється
і результати цього ми бачимо в новинах.
Поки німецький уряд не наважується поставити Україні крилаті ракети,
цього тижня стало відомо про відправлення 25 танків Leopard 1,
придбаних концерном Rheinmetall у бельгійської компанії
та двох ЗРК Patriot.